Going on. It's bill burr and his
time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday, Monday morning
podcast and just checking in on you.
This is not an official podcast.
This is where it just checking
in on you on a Thursday.
I see how you fucking work week is going
at most times what? You know the deal.
I do it by myself. I lay
around, I shoot the shit. I
say things. People hear things,
they think that it's about them and
who is or isn't in the White House,
who the fuck knows? But every once in a
while I bring on a guest and when I do,
I don't just bring on any guests.
I bring on some of the most talented
people out there and some of my great
friends and today this is no different.
I have the great Ben Bailey from cash cab.
He's got a new special,
he's got a bunch of short films.
He's got a new website.
It's got a bunch of shit he wants to
talk about. Ben Bailey. What's up man?
How the fuck are you? Good to see you now
have, when was the last time I saw you?
It wasn't last November.
Oh.
Might've been once since then,
but we had to have some sort of
festival. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe out here.
But you're talking to walking
by to some social media tent.
You're talking about a Madison
Square Garden? No, last November.
Was that a year ago already? Yeah,
it was. Who was the, uh, shit,
the no longer Toyota comedy festival.
Oh really? Is it done or it's just,
isn't it just in New
York, New York? No. Yeah.
Do you remember how many years
when we were in New York?
I came to New York and
like 95 I believe in, uh,
just a couple of years after me. I started
out here and then went back there. Oh,
okay.
And we did like what we did like maybe
four or 5,000 shows together or something
like that.
I literally sat down one time,
and this is 15 years ago now, or
maybe like 12, somewhere in there.
And I tried to sort of have,
you know,
add up some idea of how many
standup shows I had done.
What did you think I came up with
10,000. Yeah, that was, you know,
at least 10 years ago.
Probably more.
And you count a show is
every time you go on. Yeah.
Just and he said I did anywhere.
That's fair because anytime you go up
God knows what the fuck is happening and
it doesn't matter if it's
for five minutes. Yeah.
Somebody can still have plenty of time if
you kept something thrown at you. Um, I,
you know something, I remember I kept
count until about like 26 to 30 maybe,
and then I just lost it.
But I remember you got to keep a
track of how many you had done.
I probably did too. I don't even
remember it, but I probably did too.
I was always jealous of people
that did that cause I'm sorta like,
like I like I hate stats and like
trying to figure out what people,
where people are socially. But I
loved them in sports because they're,
they're like, they're kind of fact as
far as like how many home runs you hit,
you know, that's like a ladder to it
gives you some something to go up against.
Yeah. But the, I don't buy into
the bullshit like you know,
do all we're doing when it's raining
out and we'll bubble with what that when
you get to that shit, like I'm more into
the how many yards did this guy throw?
Four. How many of you run in
or whatever. Stuff like that.
Not in specific situations. They do break
it down a little too far. You're like,
what the fuck? It's the, the reason,
cause we have like nine 19 maybe 24 hour
sports networks plus Internet plus shit
heads like me and all that.
If the whole thing,
it's just way too much information and a,
what I was trying to get to was,
do you remember when the Toyota
Comedy Festival first came around?
It was the funniest shit ever.
It was just this,
they would say that it was the festival.
There was like nobody I ever
met that was connected with it.
They would just hang a banner. It was
just a banner at the regular clubs. Yeah,
and it was all the same
regular performers.
There was no industry and it would just
be, let them have SD would leave on this.
We can do, you have the
Toyota comedy festival and we
have Ben Bailey, Bill Baer,
Godfrey who was all the same fucking
people except it was a banner we used to
have.
It took us like,
we were all so excited cause we had
nothing going on in our careers.
We were like,
oh I'm part of the festival.
And it took about three years before
somebody finally just said, you know what?
What is this shit beyond the volt?
This is every,
this is a regular Wednesday. Right. And
somehow though that and morphed into a,
an actual festival into the New York
comedy festival, which is, I think,
you know, there's a lot of festivals, you
know, out there, but like New York City,
you've got to have a big comedy
festival. I think so. I think it's great.
I was actually, I had been
a part of it really. Uh,
but I'm supposed to be next year lays
the groundwork for the first nine years
when it was just the banner.
That's right.
That was a part of it for the first nine
and then they started booking people
and I missed the cut or some shit.
I don't know. Yeah. You and me both
the New York underground comedy festival,
I don't think I was a part of it.
I'm sure I submitted a VHS tape to it.
The joke was that it was so underground
that literally no one knew about it.
Was it down at like surf reality?
It was the same thing. It was like,
it was like a banner ad, a couple
of clubs, you know, and some guys,
some guy had a bunch of money.
He was like, I'm going to
have a festival, you know,
that's a great way in from La and stuff.
And these guys would come in,
they're like, Yo, we're here for the
festival and we're all like, Whoa,
what are you talking about?
I'm sure we greeted them warmly.
Fucking assholes.
Well the last time,
well I guess sort of meandering my way
towards was that Toyota comedy festival
then morphed into the New York comedy
festival and that's what that they, uh,
Msg Gig was last year. And as I mentioned,
as I mentioned to you guys, you know,
obviously that was a nerve wracking
gig and um, I just, you know,
I don't,
I can't remember how the fuck came about.
Probably from doing the goddamn comedy
jam or whatever. I was like, uh, I,
I've asked my agent, I was like, hey
wait, we paid to rent that thing all day.
Right.
And considering 90% of the money is going
to go right back to renting that giant
fucking place. I go, yeah. I said,
can I like rent a drum kit first?
I was just going to run a drum kit
and just jam with my, you know, my,
my music by myself. Typical comedian,
totally isolated, but because of Josh,
Adam Meyers in the goddamn comedy
jam, so like the people, they're like,
we're going to be in town.
So I rented all this gear and um,
there was this running thing with me
and Ben were for about eight years.
We were trying to get together
and play music. You play drums.
I play guitar and we're going to
get together every fucking time.
He'd come out here to la and it's like
he's running around, he's got meetings,
he couldn't fucking make it.
And then I get to New York and he,
you're out in Jersey and that's just
when you don't have a fucking car.
It's like, oh my God, what a, I'm
going to get on the path train to,
we'll fucking anybody
to come out gypsy cab.
So finally like we're just like,
um,
I had come to town and we were going
to jam and then that's when I, I,
we finally solidified it and I was
going to drive out to your place so,
and you are all excited cause you, you've
made it built and everything. I'm like,
oh we're finally going to play
in it and he's all amped up.
Tell me how great his fucking studio is.
And I was like, ah, I don't know man.
I think I got a better place.
And you're like, I got a
better place. I'm like, yeah,
what the fuck? And I just said,
I tend to give you the idea.
I think I told you it was MSG. I finally,
I wrote back where like that was like,
it must be someplace good.
Yeah.
He's not just slamming my home studio
that I built without having seen it yet.
It must have some good fucking venue
and then I know you cause up MSG.
Monosodium glutamate
can be fucking Madison Square Garden Man.
That I knew when I said
I have a better place.
Your next text was going to come back
in all capitals because Ben doesn't take
any shit from anybody and he's actually
big enough to beat the fuck out of me
and about 20 other people. So He's, what
the fuck? I totally insulted a studio.
So when he hit me in a better place.
Yeah. So we ended up coming down and um,
as I mentioned before, is that my phone
APP, Jesus Christ. Bill, can you feel,
it just makes it real.
It makes it real to the listeners.
People feel like they're actually in
the studio witnessing how unprofessional
this is. How many of them like
jumped up and looked around? I know,
cause I do have, when the phone rings
they're like, Oh, it's, oh no, that's,
that's the standard one.
Like if you ever hiding in the closet and
there's a serial killer walking around,
there's a chance when your phone rings,
he won't know what shoe
he'll think it's him.
He gets his phone for a second and maybe
you can drop on them, run out money.
When he goes to look at it, you fucking
smother them with your pj's. Oh,
it's a great scene in a film right there.
Oh, there you go. It's killer checks,
his own phone. He's like, God dammit.
Yeah. Could you want to do life,
be professional speaking
to play in music is,
I have like the hearing
damage that I have,
which is inevitable if you play or you
do this fucking rate of the hearing
damage that I have is I
actually got my hearing checked.
Like I still can hear everything but I
have a little bit of displacement as to
where it is.
Like it'll be to the right and I start
going to the left and my wife just for
stigma and just laughs at me.
Yeah.
And as long as it stays of disappointing
is from doing stand up and like playing
music and yeah,
having these things I know.
Oop from our opie and Anthony says my
ears are shot because what happens is it
is your ears get tired and you know,
you keep turning up and turn it up.
It's all about the
duration. All right. Yeah.
You guys do like four hours a day
and I try to be conscious of it,
but like I fucked my years up in the 80s.
One of my ears I got that Tinnitus
just rings it a real low level.
Well if I'm really hung over,
but I mean I don't have like,
like to the Pete Townsend level,
but uh, so anyways, getting back to,
so at Johnson right, he had to
quit. I know there was a DC right,
but not from the music. From race.
Car driving was just like what? Oh,
is that what it is from? Yeah, that's what
they said. It wasn't, you know, he's in,
it has been an ACDC all these years.
Like the loudest fuck band. But no,
that's not why his ears or damaged.
It's from driving race cars.
One of my first times I really fucked
my ears up as I saw them on the, uh,
what was it? The heat secret
tour. Oh No, I saw him.
I saw him at the Boston Garden. Nice.
I think Cinderella opened and, no, no,
I saw him down in Providence.
Was it different tour? I
saw them a bunch of times.
Who made, who heat seek her
out during that whole period?
I used to go see him and,
uh, I didn't have earplugs.
And as loud as that was the
fucking dude driving home,
he had the fucking thing turned
all the way up to fucking 10.
I remember just like sitting in the back
just taking it rather than asking him,
Hey, can you turn that down
yet? You're making all of it.
I had like the German Irish, just
like, yeah, don't complain, complain,
suffer in silence. It'll,
it'll be over soon. So anyway,
when you're in the back of a car and
the guy's driving like a fucking maniac,
and I'm, I'm like being
polite. Yeah. I'm like,
I don't want to offend him by
asking him to slow down or whatever.
I'd rather just risk my own death.
Hey,
not trying to be that guy that's trying
to be that guy, but, uh, I'd like to live.
I'd like to survive this ride. I don't
want to be in a halo at the end of this.
But anyway, so we finally ended up
getting to play at Madison Square Garden,
which I think it was worth
the fucking wait. That was,
that was our Chinese democracy.
And Dude, I gotta tell you, man,
I wouldn't change a thing. You fucking
can play. Oh, you can really play a man.
I was really like, you're telling
me it was crazy and I got to,
I got to show that to a, you know, a
bunch of people. When I got to do a,
the tonight show, I showed it
to a quest and Fallon and stuff.
I think I showed you. I showed it to
them and they were just like, wow, man,
you should've given us,
you know, Jimmy's all,
he should have given us the video we
would have played. It was just like,
all right, dude, it's not that good.
Quite on that level I'd like to have.
It's so fun, Dude. It really was.
It really wasn't just going off and
surreal day. Yeah. And I hit my, my, uh,
then every, every so many people play
too. Like my, my agent went up and played.
He almost didn't go. I had to twist
his arm. Yeah. Yeah, go up there.
I helped it drag him up there.
I was like, come on dude. Well,
little wing or Michael O'Brien that he
fucking ran up. I was like, Hey Mike,
you want to, and he just ran right
up. He was great too, man. So, um,
that was a fucking great day dude.
And your show is awesome and I didn't
know anything aboutF is for family before
that night. Oh, you guys
played the preview of it.
That was the first time when
she was like, Holy Shit, man,
this is going to be awesome. I
didn't even know. Yeah, great.
Well we've got another, uh, 10 episodes
of that coming out, but we're here.
We're here to, uh, promote your stuff.
Let's start with your website. Um,
the Real Ben bailey.com that's you're
relaunching your website or you just,
I'm relaunching it. It's been kind of
just, you know, very basic for a log time.
And I was like,
you know what,
it's time to just start making my own
stuff and putting it out directly to
people. Cause there's no reason
to go and try and sell, you know,
like there's two short films on there,
uh, that I made that I really love.
What's the one would Judah
Freelander that you made a while ago?
I'm dying to see that. It's funny. It's
a, it's called meet me at res. Right.
And we made it like way back in
like 2002 or something or 2003.
And then we're crazy busy after that and
it just sat there and I just looked at
him like,
I got to put this thing out.
So it's just about two idiots meeting
up for pizza at Ray's pizza in New York,
you know, but there's, there's
a lot of rays, pizzas, dude,
you got a little busy at 14 years later.
It's one of the gate newsletter.
I'm like, all right, let's put
this thing out. And then, uh,
well what happened during those
14 years? It was, you know,
he'd started doing all the movies.
You did the cash cab thing.
That was so cool watching you
guys like a blowing up. Like,
I felt like our generation
kind of had like an even thing.
It was just like nobody knew who we were.
And then all of a sudden like everybody
started like just got some inroads.
I don't know what happened. Yeah. He
felt like you were all going nowhere,
you know?
I mean,
Jude and I used to sit in his minivan
at the end of Knights of standup in New
York. It'd be like, man, this
brutal. We've got nothing.
We've got nothing going on.
You know,
dude,
I remember being in New York and then
boom and I moved back from La the first
time I was out here and I had a,
I lost my booking agent,
I had known manager, I know agent and
I was incorporated as a business and I,
it was costing me too much money.
I got unincorporated instead of paying
to be incorporated because I wasn't
making any money.
And I went all the way back to square
one and I was living in that walkthrough
bedroom apartment with the guy who,
who was on the lease and it was me
and Bobby Kelly. We had a lot of fun,
but there was definitely nights.
It's probably good that I was living with
Bobby cause we'd laugh until, you know,
you know, the late night
and then I man take it easy.
But if I had to go home and
just be with my own thoughts,
that happened that after he moved out
and then I moved out and then there was
that period about 2000 to 2004 where a,
yeah,
there was a lot of tastes just waking
up going like, uh, what am I doing?
What the fuck? I mean, dude, I had,
I mean from 2000 2004 I think somewhere
in there I did get a half hour.
Right.
But there was like a thousand spur.
I think I came to your half
hour that comedy central
one? Yeah, I think so. Yeah.
There was like a good three year period
there just being like, okay, 33 years old,
34 years, 35, you know, like fuck, this
was not the plan. Am I going to be like,
thought it was okay.
Yeah, it was. Um, yeah.
And then the whole alt scene
was coming up, you know,
and that whole thing blew up. And then we
would just, the fucking house Casco, he,
that was,
that was rough man.
When the alternative comedy club scene
developed and then just became this big
thing. You couldn't drag an industry
person. Yeah. We're just in the,
in the mainstream clubs like oops.
Well yeah you could have no idea,
but I'm not going to move to those places.
Yeah. Who a man that was those who are,
uh hey ted, those are rough ones, you
know? But we used to have changed.
Yeah. So you made that thing
like 15 years ago. What,
what's this movie that you have coming up?
Cause I know you go into the
screening here, which is really cool.
This one's called blam badly, badly
written action man. Yeah. Yeah. It's just,
you know, action movies,
the action starts with,
they are badly written
in a manner of speaking.
It's got a lot of quality in those,
but they're,
but they're like one liners are
like at least kind of clever, witty,
and even if they're over the
top off some steam. Totally.
So I was like, I just thought, I
thought of this character one day.
I can't remember what
I was doing and where,
but I just like it be funny if you know,
so much of those movies now
are built around those lines.
If when you finally get to the, you know,
one of those lines, it's just awful.
Just no pay off. Yeah. It's just
no pay off at all. You know,
which is like an anti pay off really.
So it's kind of a crazy concept,
but it just sort of fell together like,
and how long are these movies?
They're both about 10 minutes.
And this is like the type of stuff you're
going to start putting on the real Ben
bailey.com just making, yeah, I think
that's a smart idea because those,
those shorts and get psyched about it,
they ended up turning it into something.
They turn into movies. And, uh, that's one
thing I've learned about this business.
This is just like you, when you make
that decision like it, this feels right.
I'm going to do this. So many
people they do at one, two times.
And when Spielberg of Oprah doesn't
want to interview you as somebody to,
you're like, well fuck this business
tried. You just got to keep going.
Cause then when one of them hits,
then they go back to your whole library
and you got all of that stuff and
they'll something we'll uh,
will turn into it. But, um,
I hope you're worried about that dude.
Hey,
how long have you been a lot into them?
Boy is about 10 minutes and it's,
and it's, uh, it's badly
written action man,
which was originally badly
written action star. Right?
And in Lenny Marcus and I
were working on writing,
throwing around ideas about it,
and he was abbreviating it when he
wrote back to B was Blas or whatever.
Right? And that may be
going like, oh, maybe,
maybe there's something in the acronym.
Right? And then I was like, Oh,
if I make it barely written action,
man,
then that's blam and that's like
a badly written sound effect.
Oh yeah. Know what I mean? It's like,
hey, did you just kind of fell together?
You know when you feel like
something's working. Yeah.
I had all these ideas and that one went,
isn't that little stuff like that just
moved to the front, so I just made it.
When did you shoot that one? Uh, in
July. Oh, cool. Well there you go.
Now you've really stepped it up.
One took you 12 years.
This one took about 12 weeks. Yeah,
you're totally right. It's on a tear now.
Jesus Christ. But it's cool. DC Benny's
in it and I love to, he's a guy.
He's a great actor. He's so
good in this. He's so fun.
He's the evil villain and in boy,
Oh man,
I'm going to watch this and this is going
to be on a, it's in it. Vecchione is in,
it is a riot.
Masavia us in it savvy and Korea.
Dude, he'd be a perfect
instrument. So yeah,
I'm a Salvia. How we know him. He used
to run the old Boston Comedy Club,
which is now you'd fucking,
it was a wine tasting or a wine bar.
It's a wine bar yet.
I walked in there one night just,
I had to go in and look at it
and there was all these people,
their twenties you know,
prime of their fucking life like we
used to be and I just was going like,
they're like,
can I help you sir?
And I was just like this old man
comedy club and they were like, really?
And I was like, yeah, go.
I watched like a 20 year old Dave
Chappelle right where that to top is.
And that was at first they didn't
give a fuck till I dropped him.
He your pill and they're like,
really? I'm going to complete it.
And I was like all offended. Like how come
you don't know what's important to me?
Totally. I know that feeling. Yeah. It's
just like, well cause we moved on old man,
now I would like Amarillo
or get the fuck out of here.
I'm fucking leaving.
I don't do downstairs of that places now.
The zinc bar was used to be called
the beacon cafe. Used to be the,
the bag it in the bag in it and we
used to drink in their permit card.
I remember that kid with the glasses,
the kid on the guitar,
he come down a fucking like whale like
every Monday night. Colker Holy Shit.
That guy gave it coker. Yeah, I've
still been in touch with him, man. He,
we did a SAR for my last special coker
and I wrote a song and did it and play it
at the end tack yet cash cab
blues is silly like you know,
cash cab blues tune. Right.
Cause I loved poker so much.
He's such a great musician. He really, how
long have you been playing, by the way?
Uh, since I was 12. Yeah, you
can count 12 years old. I,
I uh, the guy that lived behind this
English family moved in behind us.
This is eight weeks and the old deal,
this guy,
the oldest son.
Hello show yard.
It's just your garden. I want a
guy. No, I was talking about that.
My last podcast, like every
fucking ingredients. Spice
they we say differently.
Yeah. Yeah. There's a lot
of little basil, Oregano,
Basil to my girlfriend. You've met
my girl, right? She's Australian.
I have a new bit around one
of those little things that,
uh, that still come up,
these little differences between how they
speak and how we speak. And she said,
uh, talking about my daughter
going horse riding, right.
Am like horse riding.
We say horseback riding.
And then I'm like, why
do we specify? Yeah.
Horse-Riding actually
makes a lot more sense.
They kind of get until he ever ride on
one part of the horse horseback riding.
But she just said horse
riding, get off. It's neck.
Horseneck so I had this
whole bit about it,
but there's so many little things
like that, but, so he's British.
He's British family moves in behind us.
The oldest brother is like, I'm like,
I'm 11. What are the names again? The
Sedgwick's I just want to hear you say,
and through Sedgwick,
Joan's centric
loyalty is with the urgency
of that accident is just
fucking tremendous. I would,
let's not fair. Is it the, there's
so much graphic toss. Yeah,
that comes with that accent. It's just
we can't sound so fucking important.
Everything. Yeah. So
sorry. No, that's fine too.
So the oldest brother is like 25
or 26 and he's a sound engineer.
So he's got a studio in their attic.
He builds a studio in their attic and he's
on doing sound mixing for some albums,
like so pretty big stuff like that.
What was his name?
His name was Andrew Sedgwick.
Still is as far as I know,
but so I would go over there and
annoy the shit out of this guy.
It was just a little kid who I was so
curious about it all his equipment and
stuff, his studio and everything that he
got fed up with me asking them a zillion
questions and he just put a guitar
in my hand here, play with this.
So I started playing with it and you know,
six months later I bought it.
I saved up my, my paper route
and I bought his, uh, oh,
you gotta paperwork too?
Yeah, yeah. Oh, you say rod. I
say, Bro, look at that route.
Route paper. Wait, which one did I say?
You said Ralph? I thought rob was Midwest.
I don't know. We'll see. I have a little
Midwest. I lived in Michigan when I was,
when I was little,
so I have this weird mix of accents.
They lived in the south too,
so I kind of do now. My Dad,
oh, he's a hit man. He's a killer.
So how many times were you a
the new kid in school? Uh, for,
I did it three times. It's
brutal. Fucking brutal. Right?
I still remember the kids
that were nice to me. Yeah.
I still remember when I
moved the last time we moved.
Oh maybe the second time this kid Keith
Hannon, the first recess goes, hey man,
you want to play catch?
And he had a tennis ball and you're like,
and I was just like, oh thank
God. Cause he wasn't bad enough.
It was bad enough coming in like we
were like 40 we moved to the town and we
were like four days a week.
It was already four days in
the school year, right? Yeah.
Then we came and I had a very similar
thing man and how they bring you in and
he's like, you don't just shit.
Like I didn't just show up.
I didn't get on the bus
or anything like that.
Like we went down to the principal's
office because we were late and everything
and they were like,
all right.
And they just walked us down and she just
came walking in and going, okay class.
We have a new student.
They're all looking at me like I kind
of like a energy my way through the last
one I hung my coat up like, hey, how
are you? I've made a lot of noise.
I went over and I sat down and
then that's why I just sat down.
I felt like cost my desk. I felt it was
like right in the middle of the class.
I just felt everybody glancing me,
I was like,
I have to sit down with my
fucking orange hair. Like I know,
I know I don't like it either.
Fuck off.
So it's brutal. Being the new
kid is fucking hard. I was Paul,
like I was a big Kid Kinda at that
age in high school I wasn't that big.
Everyone sort of caught up with
me and then I drew again later.
But when I was in fourth grade,
I was one of the bigger kids.
So it seems like it'd be great.
But no,
all the kids who were the bigger guys
want, I had to like fight them. Yeah.
I had a fight my way through
first day of school. They were,
people were choosing who I had to fight
on the fucking playground. I'm like,
this is not lost. I always
lost. I fought this kid.
I remember I thought this kid,
this is sorta Kinda when I look up,
but like it was sort of racist
the way the teacher handled it.
He was the only black kid and
for some reason we fought.
We fought like five recesses in the
road. He kept kicking my ass. Finally.
I remember I was starting to win it.
He had these fucking work boots on and
then you just went like Bam, Bam, Bam,
like three times in my shin. I
was like, well I started crying.
I was just sitting there crying.
I remember she fucking,
as we used to say back then,
balled him out is what do we
successfully getting yelled at?
Yelled at him and then came on
and I was sitting there crying.
She came home and she like rubbed my head.
She even thought so you
just got away with it.
It's kind of like maybe cause you
lost cause that was so pathetic.
Or maybe I just looked like a little,
a little beat up Ron Howard.
I don't know what Ralph Malphurs
something ginger. Yeah, she was,
I actually thought about later
like why was she comforting me?
We both got into it every fucking recess.
I was clearly not like trying
innocent too to get away from the kid.
I didn't even know why we will fight
neither cause then we ended up being like
friends.
It was just like that little kid shit.
And I still remember somehow I slipped
and fell and when I did during the fight.
Yeah. And then he had this work
boots. I think he fell down to,
maybe we just work with the heel of
his boot tongue sticking out, you know,
little kids when they're really
trying to make an effort. That was it.
Crying
cry.
Even if I won the fights when I was a kid.
Oh cause just the emotion.
I always tell him I was
at a birthday party,
we were playing street hockey and this
one kid who played hockey was like really
good.
He kept lifting my stick and kept taking
the puck and he was like fucking twice
my height. I got stuck in your
stickup. Yeah. And I got so mad.
I turned around and I just
started fighting him and he just,
he just kind of like,
he like leaned back and kind of like,
let me fucking get like three,
four in like missing Kinda.
And then he just went blam and fast
glass to me in the side of the head and I
fell down.
I started crying and I walked away and
I just remember screaming the top of my
lungs and I was walk.
Cause I used to cut through the woods
and people were yelling from the party to
get to school. No know I cut to the
woods to get to my friend's house.
Where were you before?
We played street hockey.
So I was already into the woods and
people were screaming guy, come on up,
I'll come back. And I was in the
middle of was very sound going. Fuck.
I think his mother yelled at one time
and I just went home in the woods alone.
And this is the maturity of the other kid.
This is no,
just see a walking through the trail.
Yeah.
Head was always such a real
moment. Yeah, no, look,
I lived the same thing.
And what was funny was I came home and
I told my mother what happened and um,
it never dawned on her to call over there
to drive me all that, all that overly,
just getting involved with Shit,
parenting that people have
done it over the last,
like whatever since we were kids.
She just was like, all right,
when you get home, yeah, well you
know, I have things to do or whatever.
And then that was kind of it.
And I remember the next day,
the maturity of the other kid
was, um, when we were on the bus,
I was like ignoring them and stuff and
he just kind of yelled at, you know,
everybody stands up. He waiting to
get off the bus, he yell, hey bill,
let me talk to you. Uh, when we get
off the bus. And I was like, oh,
we got off the bus. That's cool.
Yeah. This is his fifth grade.
He really just goes like, yeah, sorry
about that. I was that guy, man.
And it was fun. Yeah. I should
have learned that lesson,
but I didn't cause the fuck that kid.
No, I should say his name.
You remember his name? Yeah.
I don't want to say everybody's,
and I probably shouldn't say that because
people get all weird and she's still
rather actually real people who are still
alive. Yeah. His first name was Tom.
Put it that way. It's a tall
fucking dude, dude. Dude.
I was way out of my
fucking way class and he,
and even even the ass kicking
was a gentlemanly as kicking.
He just gave me one shut the fuck up
to sit down. Quiet little kid. Yeah.
There was no reason for me to fight you.
I was just mad because he was better than
me. It was just, it was really immature.
Even for that age, I'm still ashamed
of myself. So, um, so anyway,
so this guy ended up giving
you a good time. That's for me.
That's really fucking cool
car. Yeah, it was so cool. Uh,
I guess she had the
paperwork. I got it. Well,
I mean I could go over there and play it
whenever, but at some point I was like,
I'm going to save up and buy it. I think
I bought it for like 75 bucks. Did He, uh,
he teach you any codes or anything or
was he no, no, he just left me to it,
you know, but then I like my girl, uh,
my sister's boyfriend was a guitar player
and he was quite a bit older and like,
so he showed me some stuff. And
pretty soon I was like, you know,
I knew I could figure out some songs.
I always had a decent ear.
I could pick stuff out and find it.
But that was the only, that was,
unless you had the money to take lessons,
that was the only way to learn back then.
That was it. I felt like lessons, no,
you know, like kids today, the shit
that they could see on youtube,
someone will just totally break that thing
down, which is great. Which is great.
And that's why there's so many
monster players out there. But like,
I would suggest if, you know,
as they start to show it,
to sort of turn your back to the screen
and see if you can just listen to what
he's doing. And it just, just so you'll
always develop in Europe because I,
I wouldn't want to be that guy. Like, you
know, couldn't figure it out. Like, yeah.
Well that's like literally in and out.
Yeah. You know, but I also think that, uh,
maybe one sort of downfall of all of
everything being out there for anybody to
learn is you don't develop
your own style of guitar, like,
or whatever it is, right?
Like I play guitar differently
than most people, I think,
because no one ever really taught me
how to play, I just started playing it.
Right. So I have little, little things
that I do that are probably unique to me.
At least. I hope they are right.
It's a technique that would be like,
actually that's a, and that's
wrong. You're holding your
hand wrong or, you know,
you should always still sounds good. But
yeah, they were like, well, but it's,
this is what I do. So, you
know, but I think music is like
that, you know, it's, it's,
it's your expression, whatever, whatever
you do, that's what you do. So yeah,
it's definitely a,
it's kind of a great thing for it.
And it's also a weird thing because then
I, I definitely, there's always like,
then there's like the top
like fucking, uh, it's just,
I feel like everybody's influenced now is
whatever subject it is, the first page,
the first three links, right. Becomes
like 90% of people's like consciousness.
Because if you look at, I should
probably, cause I even do that,
she probably don't want to go on Youtube
next time I go to look something up to
try, just click to like, boy,
what the fuck is on page three.
Like I want to get into the
age of 99. What the hell's
on their underground? Yeah.
There's 100,000 pages to
look at most things. Right.
100,000 hits on how to
play. You know, I played,
I played right before I came over here.
I'm doing another one of those, uh,
the goddamn comedy jam. So I
have another song. I got it.
I got to try to get together,
which is song or you can't say,
I don't want to ruin it cause it's,
cause it's part of the show when
they get there. But it's a, you know,
I always stay pretty much, you
know, seventies and eighties.
I dress up like the drummer
that I'm going to tell.
It's just completely ridiculous.
Yeah. Cause it's a want to do,
I want to do one of those with those guys.
I gotta I gotta connect with
them cause they were like,
you should do and when you come out
next, but now it's been a year. Yeah.
You'd kill it. That'd be so
fun. Dude. I wonder if the,
I don't know if Josh and those
guys came up for the, uh,
the Toyota and now New York comedy
festival. I think they were there.
I think they were in New York for that
dude. I have so much fun with those guys.
And one year I did Montreal
comedy festival just to come in.
I played with those guys three nights in
a row. Oh, it's just to do it. And then I,
then I did a standup show, but like the
reason I was there was to do the music.
Yeah. Because I played, dude,
I played full fucking like 20
years by myself. Like it was so,
uh, two same thing man.
But it was such like a, um,
like a kind of thing of like why I ended
up becoming a comedian because I was so
introverted and like it,
like it didn't dawn on me until like the
mid two thousands I started playing in
the 80s. That was just like, hey,
kind of the reason for playing is to
interact with other human retain yet to
share it with people.
Yeah. Yeah. And then, uh,
thank God that that show came around
than the first time I got to like, well,
I sat in with a few other people, but the
first time I actually kind of came out,
people knew who fuck I wasn't had sit
down and was, it was a really like,
was such a fun thing.
So I'm playing music live is like
different than stand up obviously,
but it's so great.
But I think it's just love it man.
It's your fun for us too because we're
not in a band and we don't have to deal
with that because I know that uh, guys
have met, there are actually in bands.
It's like the big thing is
how to keep it fun and B,
when it starts becoming a job, like you've
talked with other Comedians, you know,
when you told with ca means you're
going to have the substance abuse guy.
You got the Pussy Hound,
the late guy, the EGOMANIAC.
Those are all the same guy.
Yeah, that's all Tony Woods,
isn't it? Some tiny.
Tell him I'd have a couple of, we
all have a couple of lows. I'm one,
I'm a one or two of those guys
from time to time. But yeah,
I mean what two are you, would you say
I'm late and uh, what were the other ones?
Substance Abuse. Uh, EGOMANIAC pussy out.
I would say I am,
uh,
I'm definitely late and maybe at the
talks of substance abuse, substance abuse,
Guy Cigars, drinking. I can you,
I don't know if this makes
me a fucked up or anything,
but like I know I could shut it off
anytime I want to. I just don't want to,
what do you mean to the drinking or the,
and he's like, yeah, I could go. I did it.
I did you, I know you went
a few years. I want to like,
I did like a year and some change.
You know, you're in a couple of days.
I was just like,
I just,
I missed it but it's that something
get like completely like ruins my uh,
ruins my, I'm like, I dunno. I mean I,
I know when to do it.
I do it much,
much more controlled than I used to.
Like when I stopped I stopped cause
I was like, Holy Shit, this is,
I'm out of control here. Oh, all right.
I gotta I gotta is way off and
regain my footing. So, oh yeah.
I think that's the difference between
like maybe addicts and like fucked up
people like you and I where it's
just like I can just, I just,
when it gets out of control I was like,
hi,
well I'm not going to do that for like a
month, you know, stop for awhile. Yeah.
Although this year, you know, I kept
saying that and it was never a month.
It was always like three, four days. I
had a really stressful year this year.
Just a lot of stuff. It's
just career stuff. Being busy,
being busy, being busy, all my
free time kind of fucking, yeah.
Dissolved and uh, sitting there, you
know, writing on a show, it was just,
you come home,
your brain is fried and I probably
should have picked a better habit,
but it started to becoming, coming
home and having a whiskey. Right.
And then it became two
and then it became three.
And then my wife is finally like,
ah, hey, you fucking booze bag.
What are you doing? Literally called me
a bully bag and then I, then I, uh, I,
I dialed it back and for
me it's just, it's, it's,
could you like laugh when she'd said
that? Oh God, yeah. You weren't like,
that's good. No, my wife is a lawyer. You
know, you've got all mad and be like, no,
wait a minute. I knew
that I was, I did that.
Now that would have been a bad if that's
your reaction and we need to think
about yes. Standing there and I'm like,
yeah, you're right. I need to rate it in.
Sorry. Then you're done. It's cool. Yeah.
I just had a couple of bottles hidden
behind toilets and shit. That's totally,
that's totally normal. No, I think,
I think everybody kind of needs to have
some little shit that's just there.
It's like, or like a little thing
that you keep just for, you know,
you have to do it right.
You know what I mean?
Like everybody's got a s maybe some
secret little shit. That's whatever it is.
I saw this guy one time, this old dude.
I'm going to move the mic here. I'm sorry.
I got to lean back at some
point. Have bad posture. Um,
I saw this one time I was staying
at this hotel. Right, right.
And there was this old dude
standing there. All right.
And like every night like clockwork,
because I would finish the shows,
I'd come home, he'd come walking
out as soon as hotels you could, uh,
he had a little dog or whatever.
Nowadays everything's like a fucking
therapy dog so he can get away with it.
It's a working dog working dealt.
You're not supposed to ask. Yeah,
I asked the guy in the airport, he's
like, you're not supposed to ask about it.
Well, I did. I'm like, you know, well,
if he didn't have a sweater
that said working dog on it,
I wouldn't have fucking
asked. Yeah, what's its job?
What's going to major in
business? So sorry. Um,
every night this guy would come out and
he would eat, take out a little pouch.
It was tobacco by the way.
He'd take that out and he would roll his
own cigarette and it was, I just saw it.
It was like, this is this
guy's whole ritual, you know,
sat there and he would only
smoke one and he would just,
he would milk it and he would make it
last for like a half hour and he would
just sit out there quietly,
no phone, no IPAD, no nothing.
And um, I remember seeing
that going like, yeah,
I get what that guy's doing and
I wish I had the time to do, uh,
to do a little more
that we just have that,
that I think guys kind of need like
alone time. I don't know how women are.
Women are a little more social,
but I agree they probably need it too.
I have no idea. I shouldn't
speak for them. I don't know.
My girl seems content to just
be together and you know,
and talk and chat about everything
all the time. And sometimes I'm like,
why am I getting all cranky
and fucked up right now?
And like I just need to be by myself like
I needed. I definitely need alone time.
I think that's why we've got a
million things going on. You know?
We also are these careers or are all
consuming if you let them be right.
Cause we don't have an office,
we don't punch a clock.
We don't show up at one time
and then leave at another.
It's just always going on. Right. You
have ideas, you have creative ideas,
you have schedule shit that you're
keeping track of things going on.
When I shot my special right on
the 21st of October, I was like,
oh this here just shot a new one. Yep.
All I gotta do is just fucking, you know,
edit that thing. Look at it
a couple times, cause I know
what I want and I'm like,
and I'm just fucking done.
Then I'm that time to Christmas shop.
I'm going to fucking put my feet up, play
some drums and blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. I mean, I don't know. I don't know
what's happening. I'm fucking more, uh,
more busy than ever. And it's just
like all of these, uh, I dunno.
I just, I, I don't know anything. What's
going to, it's going to take a wild ride,
but I've been able to do at this
time where I sat through and, um,
I watched the whole fucking thing, which
is something I is, you know, it's brutal.
It's you for a fucking hour
and a half and, and the
longer you watch it, you like,
it's not even funny anymore. Yeah. You
can't pick, you're going to get yet.
It's fuck, oh my God, it's an old bid
or fuck. But every time I go to do one,
there's like a major, like I say, you
know, you, you donate a kidney. He just,
there's always a chunk. I'm like,
get that the fuck out of there.
And just go right to the
end and then we're done.
And today I figured out what it was
and it went from, uh, you know, well,
I felt a little bit too long to now
being like, oh fuck, it's over already.
Which is that sweet, sweet spot. Yeah,
you don't, you don't want to have it.
Um,
it's,
it's about 77 so that's about an hour,
15 hour in 16. But I mean, it was,
it was getting way,
it was getting,
like when they took all the footage
from both shows, it was like,
look at hour 38 and like,
all right, there's no way.
So we cut it down and then it was like
one 29 and I'm like, but I like him,
but I liked everything. But I'm
just saying, I think you have to,
if you'd like release like a concert
movie, I think it's going to be,
I would think like 90 minutes
if people cannot just, yeah.
And it's meant to be a feature.
Uh, I just feel like Netflix,
if you're going to go on there and people
are going to sit down and if you're
lucky enough, if you lucky enough that
are actually going to click on your shit,
it's just like you just gotta like,
you gotta go ACDC on him, you know,
where they don't play any balance.
You just got to fucking just
walk right through. Yeah.
Unless you're like Chapelle which
Chappelle has that way where he can,
he can just really fucking
like bring it that like,
he like just watching him do that
opening monologue on, on SNL. I mean,
just like the level of shit
that he's doing effortlessly,
not even consciously the ups and downs,
peaks and valleys in them,
the huge laughs and then the
poignant moments and all of that.
It's just like that that was,
you know,
I'd be happy if I could have done in
an hour and a half. What the fuck?
He didn't like eight minutes,
that clinic that he,
uh, that he put on. So,
um, yeah, he's nice speech.
Amazing super talented
guy. Man. Always was.
I always was when he was standing where
someone's drinking white Zinfandel right
now where the Boston comedy club
is. Hey, so what did you, uh,
um, were you shocked
about the election? Uh,
resort? I wasn't that shocked. Uh, I was,
we finally met somebody who called it.
I knew somebody had to bet Trump.
I didn't bet Trump, I didn't want
a bet Trump, but I did a tour.
I was on tour in a lot of
southern states for, you know,
the month leading up to the election
and nothing but Trump signs.
Right. I mean, that's all I stand on. When
she got to see a single, Hillary saw him.
I saw hundreds of Trump
signs and I was like, this,
this could, this might be real. Holy Shit.
I do never in a million
years than I think.
I thought Hillary was the main person
at the end of the day is going to be a
tour. You know, it's funny, I did it.
I did a Conan the day after the, uh,
the election and like,
you know,
I got so many people like fucking
yelling at me thinking like,
how the fuck would you
say this about Hillary?
How the fuck could you
say that about Trump?
Like you can't say anything about anybody.
I try to evenly trash both
of them and just say, Hey,
it'd be nice to people
stop yelling at each other.
Somehow people missed all of that
and they, they, they, you know,
I think especially the Hillary people
because they're so disappointed that they
just need somebody at the,
I kind of so much fucking shit from
people and I'm actually just texting me
going like, hey man, I saw you on that.
I go, the guy was like, it seemed like,
you know, secretly you voted for
Trump. And then he wrote secretly,
secretly, again twice. And
that was just like, yeah,
like at now I didn't vote
for that guy. No, I didn't.
I didn't vote for either one of them.
I couldn't stand them. I like Bernie.
Bernie was my fucking guy.
I felt like right after the
election for the first time,
I felt like Bernie would've won.
I was like,
people really want to change
it. You know? They don't,
they don't know how to get it.
And they kind of gave me the same old
with Hillary. Yeah. And if, if I was like,
Holy Shit,
if Bernie had gotten the nomination,
he would probably be the right now
people think Joe Biden could have won.
I think just like, like I don't, I don't
like familiarity breeds contempt. I mean,
everybody's fucking filthy.
There was just something about like,
I felt myself saying it like when I saw
Jeb Bush and I saw a Kleenex, sorry,
I just can't deal with another Bush or
Clinton. It's such a stupid thing to say,
but I was just saying it's true.
There's some truth to it because I
want somebody else to lie to me now.
I didn't want anything like this guy.
I didn't want this guy, you know?
I'm not saying Bernie would've
fucking solid everything.
We'll say all this shit that Trump's doing
is fucking hilarious. Where he's like,
I'm going to do this. I want to do that.
I'm going to drain the swamp. It's like,
dude, okay, let's just say you actually
go in there and you somehow do this.
How slow DC works. Like you're going to
fucking drain the swamp and then what?
Expose all these people and then
they're all going to go to jail and like
they're going to be okay with this.
No,
I'm going to get all the illegal
immigrants out of this country. You're,
you're going to do, how are you going to
do that? How you going to do that? Yeah.
Yeah.
I'm going to build a fucking wall from
here to fucking California to Texas a
really, you're gonna, you're gonna do
all of this through. I think there are,
there already is a wall for one,
isn't there?
There's already a fence and a wall
through a lot of it. It's like, dude,
he put on at road can't stop people from
coming in by blocking off 3% of the,
of the border.
It's a tiny,
it's like they're coming in
any way they could come in.
My thought he was going to build
the whole basis of the country.
He wasn't an people get to come in
from all over the fucking place. Well,
is how I actually think about
that shit. It's like, um,
there does become the tipping point where
you got too many fucking people. Yeah.
There is that. I mean, back in the
day, yeah. We need him, you know,
we need it all we could get because of
what we were doing, which was underhanded.
We need, it's when the, he was great,
but we needed to take all this PA yeah.
Get out there on the front lines and
they would stuck them out west. Hey,
that's your land over there. Go over there
and then provoke them into an attack.
Like what the hell? So fucking thing was
shady. Um, yeah, from the beginning, Eh,
it's not, it goes for elections. Well,
you know, it's crazy. Government,
they've been corrupted and fucked up
since the beginning. I'm not gonna,
I'm not going to say the show, but I
recently did a show, right. And uh,
one of the comics went up and this person
went and just trashed Donald Trump.
This is after, after the show, after the
election. I want the show after the show.
They went up after the show,
after the election, right.
It was like the full five days after
whatever they went, right. And uh,
went in hard on Trump,
blah blah blah.
He's a sex offender and Anna are all
this type of stuff and graduated,
the crowd started booing, right? Half
the crowd after crowd fucking booze.
So then the next person goes
up who is a Trump supporter.
This person goes up and supports
Trump and trashes Hillary.
Then the other half of the crowd started
but with them I've never seen like so
divided dude.
It's literally like,
it's like a great SCC football game
where they play in like a neutral site.
Like when Florida plays Georgia and like
it's half fucker bulldogs have gators.
It's fucking insane.
Like I've never just like that.
If the country is so completely
divided that it's a little scary.
But the thing that I don't like
is that now the p, you know,
whatever side you're on, where you're
seeing the other side as your enemy,
right. When we're not supposed to
be enemies. We're all supposed to,
we all live here together, so
that ship's sailed it. I know.
That's what I'm saying.
That's what's shitty news came in
and balanced out CNN by being just as
ridiculously far to the other side.
I mean there's those shells, those,
those networks that are hilarious.
Like when on election night what I would
do is I would just, whoever was winning,
I would watch the other network just
to watch some stuff into the sweat they
said, yeah, and just go, no, I
just, just for the comedy of it,
because I knew there was nothing.
Not that,
I mean I voted for who I wanted to vote,
find new.
This fucking state was going to go
with Hillary Clinton. I mean that's a,
that's a given.
The oceans vote for blue and everybody
else in the middle of votes for red and
then it comes down to like fucking Ohio,
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin.
Evidently North Carolina,
which I didn't know about that,
but what I was happy it was actually was
up to date on all the propositions and
voted read them all.
Me and my wife will read them for like
days in front of me and like we're just
laughing our ass off if like, can we sit
in there like reading? They'd be like, uh,
you know, do you not want them to drill
for oil in the middle of your forehead?
And then here's the argument for,
and he'd be like,
well that would probably lead to
your death. There is no oil in there,
blah blah blah, blah, blah. And then
it'd be like, the argument gets,
actually it's the complete opposite.
Drilling for oil would actually save this,
this, and next thing you know that
you're like, oh, maybe I should vote.
Like I didn't get anything out of those
arguments and then we will just laughing.
We did. You just eventually look
at, well, who supported this?
It'd be like if it was anything
environmentally, it's like Ed Begley Jr.
All right, that guy's been
riding a bike for 30 years. Okay.
If he's done with this,
I'm going with that bag is powers whole
neighborhoods by ride Neveah running on
a hamster wheel. You know, it's
funny. I do. Do we know who, um,
what happened with the condoms in
Porno? Did that pass or no? Nice.
Actually a thing. Yes. Keep Porno.
Keeps some jobs here and uh,
in, in the valley, right? So no,
they don't have to work on
them, so no, no. I think that
that was like, if they do,
they do. Yeah, they do. Okay. Oh, this
is classic Americans. We don't even know.
All right, I'll look it up.
We're going to look it up.
I thought it used to be that way
and now that they've taken it,
I had to wear condoms and then they
were having a hard time. I think it was,
you could not be further off the Mike. So
you gotta make a quick point here. Okay.
It didn't pass.
So they don't have to wear condoms,
but they can't get permits right now.
They're having a really
hard time getting it.
Okay. So porno permits were
saying that maybe it passed,
but they can't get permits now.
Jesus Christ shoot things to
vote on other than officers.
We had a vote on whether or not we want
it to allow casinos in northern Jersey.
And what'd you say? I said
No. Uh, which, and it didn't.
It was no, it was overwhelming. No,
they're not going to be able to put
casinos in northern jersey, which is,
in my opinion, very good. Right? I
don't hate casinos. The Christie's,
but I don't think they should
be everywhere. So just say,
Chris Christie is fat and
I copped he's fat enough.
He doesn't mean to get in that dead skin
bag going to jersey. Mike's even more.
And the other one was like,
should we designate the
money from tolls and fuel tax
into
right
trans public transportation, which is
first question to be four to begin with.
First question is, well, where's it
going now? Uh, well anywhere else.
I don't know where, why do I really
don't know where? But it was meant to be,
be allocated toward that a certain
percentage of it initially.
And then that got changed
somewhere along the line. So we,
ours was like voted changed it back was
legalizing weed keeping it illegal or
something like that. It was the condoms.
It was like a, should we repair it?
There was one about building up schools
and everything were initially you're
like, yeah, this is a good
thing. And then the whole thing,
the whole proposition
was written by these,
this group of people that are builders.
And wait a minute,
I like that the contractors
are right. This shit up. So
what's going on with this?
Um, they want to be a lot of interesting
shit. Yeah. There wasn't a, yeah, no,
I can't remember how there was like,
it was like at least another 12.
There was so many, any or vote
on every one of them. Yeah.
But what was great was we,
we've figured out the best we could what
it was and God knows what is attached
to all of that shit too.
Right. You know what I mean?
So I had all my answers before I went in
there. So what was taken everybody like,
you know, a good 20 minutes of your
reading it for the first fucking time.
I add them all. So I would just look at
the page. Yes. Was Up. No, it was down.
I would just look at my answer
sheet and I'd be like up,
down, down, up. And I just,
I just fucking throw it. I was great. I
felt like I was cheating on a test. Um,
well let, before we get out of it, we,
we should, we got to get the answer here.
What's going on? It did not pass yet.
It did not pass. It did not pass.
But they can't get their permits to make
porn and stuff. Yeah. Even that is comp.
Who's behind? Who's, who's a conservative
behind that, that wants to get porn.
A lot of the valley did the Tipper
Gore moved to the valley recently.
Remember her earthy TRC,
one guy that wrote it up and if it passed
he would have a job for the rest of
his life. Basically making sure there
were condoms important. So he was
so one weight. One guy wrote on it,
one guy that does not sound real.
That's what I could do that.
Yeah.
He's the one guy who supplies
the porn and asked to get,
it's got to get through some sort of
fucking legislative horse shit. Right.
Did that get put on a bounce so
he's got money? Yeah. All right.
Because I would say then the guy who
said the rent is too damn high. What?
He got something done.
Remember that guy? Yeah. Yeah.
In New York when it's too
damn rent is too damn high.
I hate it when like he kept getting labs
and kept hanging around and then like
one of those politicians like
I agree with them though.
Rent is too darn high.
I don't know how those politicians exist
and that level of phony cartoons. Yeah.
Yeah.
Algo was one of the most,
was the one of the worst I saw and that
was the thing I think about Trump that
was amazing was watching
him just be beat himself,
which a lot of people don't like who
he was, but he was being a person.
A lot of people don't think a good
person, but like he was candid. You can't,
you can't accuse him of not being dude.
It was like there was
sitting at the table,
but it was politicians and he was the guy
running the table and no one could get
them. I couldn't fuck up none. They
could not figure out. They're like,
this guy doesn't care about anything.
How do we pin him down?
And he didn't give a shit about what
he says from one minute to the next.
He didn't care about care. You'd be like,
oh, she's allowed to talk and I can,
I'll great three against one, three, three
against one. But he said that it was,
it was fucking cause it's very ticket,
but it was brilliant. Like do what he did.
I mean,
I'm not happy that it certainly these
fucking guys that he's putting together,
I jumped to my last podcast,
you know, he was talking to,
he's going to have change and everything
that we just go because he's just doing
the exact opposite. It's
like fuller house. He's just
bring it back. This old show.
I said it was like the expendable version
of the expendables of Republicans.
It's just do it. It's the whole
thing to him was just a game.
It seems if you talk, if you see him
interviewed, no, it's just like he,
he's basically like, oh,
I won and that was it.
It doesn't matter how you know,
it's just one you don't have worried
about to someone when they're like,
but you're going to,
you're doing all this stuff that you've
just said you weren't going to do.
And he's like, well, who else is to do it?
Basically it's like Marx brothers Shit.
Like you can't just say who else is
going to do it? That's not an answer,
but it didn't give a shit.
It's like this is the way that's
as good an answer answers.
You're cutting so fuck you.
But the thing about the media is they
had no followup because they never dealt
with a guy like this who would just
admit to you got to get, you know,
their old typical followup doesn't work
because they call him out on it and he
just says, yeah, whatever. Who Cares?
And it says something else. Well,
the back in the day when
somebody would call,
when they would call a politician out,
they try to get out of it and they would
stammer and then they would just keep,
you know,
hitting them with it until just the
whole embarrassment of the situation.
The person would drop out,
he just would admit to it and,
and they had nothing and they're
like, well, when they said, oh,
he used to supposed to be
bad. I keep using this as
the example that we like you,
you know, you've said this about
women, you've said that about women,
you said this about. And
he goes, Nah, Nah. He goes,
I said that about Rosie O'donnell and
it got a huge laugh and then the female
report, it goes like, no, you've said that
about other women too when he just goes,
yeah, he probably right, but
then that's over and it was over.
You made a joke and
she couldn't even like,
or anybody in that panel couldn't
have been like, you're probably right.
So you're saying you are sexist.
Is that what you're saying?
Do you think that like,
and I still think because of,
of what the fuck he represented, he
could've just been like, yes, I am sexist.
Yeah, I can't believe you're not sitting
here and making me a pie or something.
They get out of here and
let the men handle it.
Clearly people were not put off by that.
I don't know.
But it's so hard to tell what's
what's true and what is it,
anything you read about Hillary in the
last three months or five months or
whatever, it could have been
taken out of context. Absolutely.
Putting away to make her look, you
know, show her in a certain light.
And same with Trump.
It gets to be silly to assume that
one side is doing it in one side.
The other is not. No, they all are.
It's very difficult to tell what the
fuck is real and what isn't. You know,
you know, it was fun with that. Their news
from fucking Twitter, guilty as charged.
I know. Me Too, man. Me,
Facebook, all of that. I, I um,
you don't kill me. We'll put Bailey
on Twitter by Real Ben Bailey.
The Real Ben Bailey, B a I l e
y.com, the Real Ben bailey.com.
I,
um,
I was actually amazed at the election
night when they had the pictures of each
candidate and was finally one
that the other side hadn't picked.
And I was just like, oh, look at Hillary.
She looks like a nice person. Donald.
He looks like a cool guy.
Yeah, they look as Donald was.
Donald was always like the scowl and
he had like the thing like that Rudy
Giuliani picture that the left is
using where he looks like he's roaring.
He just came up from the flames of
hell. That thing is fucking, you could,
you could do that to anybody,
especially when you're totally, yeah.
When you're that old, you know this,
it's such an effort just to speak.
Your face is going to contort
and they just have to do,
take a couple of pictures. You're going
to look like Satan. And then Hillary,
he always just had that crazy fucking
smile and the bobblehead thing going and,
and really unflattering light. Like
she looked like, you know, I'll do,
they did every kind of went toward,
they did everything they possibly
could to both of them. Like Trump,
like his eyebrows by the end of the
election were like beneath his eyes.
It's like, well, thank shock. The fact
that he actually has one points out,
the point that he made
repeatedly through the campaign,
which is at the whole system is it is
fucked. It doesn't work. Right? Yeah.
But I will tell you all those people
that think that he's somehow going to get
them out of that fucking hole is,
that's ridiculous.
They don't give it. It's on you. It's on
you. And they try to act like these, uh,
these people are going to save you
fucking ass. They're not. No, they can't.
No. And that's the uplifting message.
If this podcast could be worse, dude,
there's like,
there's like a billion people,
literally a billion people in China that
live in abject poverty. Oh, totally. In,
are brainwashed into thinking that
that's, you know, that's their place.
I don't know. It's a billion
people. I know. It's like,
what the fuck?
How would you even begin to,
have you seen this is the thing tackle
an issue like that? Have you seen it?
No way to do it. It's, it's just
that's how, that's how it is.
Have you seen those cities?
Like they,
they have a few cities over there
then I have so many fucking people.
Like it literally looks like there's
a fire but it's just the polluted air.
It's just the area.
It's just the air.
So like when they were having the Olympics
over there at some point when they
were going to shoot something, you
know, film it for the world to see,
they told everybody to like not drive
or use any machinery or anything.
God knows what would happen to you if you
did. It felt like, like, I don't know,
24 hours or three days of some shit before
they just let all of that shit in the
air just settle down onto the ground.
Cause that's, that's what it is.
Yeah. Because it's all
like, even like out here,
like a lot of times people think
they, the haze is smog, but like Hays,
like smog is Brown.
But Hays is that clear thing and that
haze is all the dust and all the shit that
we're kicking up driving around. Yeah.
So everybody at bay, I think basically,
what's that new thing the kids are doing?
You act like a mannequin or some shit.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
They made like a billion people or
half a billion people fucking do that,
do that. And then people
were just like, Eh,
it is a great place to
have people go swimming.
You guys just have to hold still until
we're done with the hundred meter
backstroke. Well, get out of here dude.
When oil, there's a couple more things
on there that don't have any lecture,
any more movies or something like Di.
Do you know like the next one that you're
going to do? As far as the short film?
I don't, I think I might do
another episode of Blam. I
like it. I like it a lot.
Uh, and it was really fun and like the
idea was that another comic or you know,
actor friend of mine will be the be
the villain, probably another comedian.
And so we'll just keep doing those. But
I can definitely see that being a series,
a web series. It was a niche initially
was going to be a web series,
but then I made the
first one and I was like,
I dunno if I want to put all that into
this every single time just on my own.
Right. I might rather try
some other stuff and said,
I want to see what people like,
you know,
get some feedback once the stuff
is out there. And he'd go, oh,
that leads to something. And next thing
you know, you know you have something on,
you got something on fucking
Amazon or Netflix. Yeah.
Like you're walking down a red carpet.
People yell at Ben, what are you wearing?
What are you wearing? Oh my God, I
don't know. And then they go back.
Then they go back through
all your and, and uh, uh, uh,
recently unearthed gem meet
at race and made me a race.
And you sat me also have, yeah, for
12 years now it's a period film.
Well, I actually was anyway, I want to
see it because I want to see like I,
cause I'm,
I'm one of those guys that I love seeing
New York and any error that it isn't
now.
Like I love seeing it in the nineties now.
I love seeing it in the 80s I
love seventies of this shit.
And then the sixties and fifties
when it goes back is like I'll watch,
I watch old fucking
movies for that reason.
Like sometimes I'll watch an old movie
and I'll see a guy driving down sunset
and you just see how spread
out the buildings are and
how, I mean the shooting,
so you don't know about the traffic,
but it's just like some of
that stuff where it was just,
you could just see the hills
and stuff. It's like, yeah,
that back then that's what they had.
Like you want to go shoot a mountain
lion and you're like walked out your
backyard. He's writing, he's
just right down the road.
Yeah. In, in La. So anyways,
but I should say before we go,
sorry.
I also have two podcast shows that are
going to be on this, on the new website.
Oh cool. Uh, one of them's a storytelling
show. Beautiful. Remember DC?
Benny and I used to do that
show. Urban myth. Yeah. Wait,
what, what, what venue did,
did that,
was that,
I just almost got to this earlier
when we're talking about zinc bar,
cause that was the original onc bar was
on Houseton Street do urban myth every
Tuesday. The new podcast I have is called
tall, but true. It's a storytelling show.
It's been, it's pretty much urban myth.
Oh, cool. As a podcast. So it's like the,
the two of us tell a story and
then a guest tells a story.
So I'd love to have you do that call into
that if you want. And then another one,
and that'll all be on the
real Ben bailey.com. Yeah.
And then one where my girl and I,
it's called speaking of movies,
we watch a movie and then we just
talk about the movie afterwards.
It goes around, which we love, which we
did anyway. And then one day we're like,
we always have these great
conversations after we watch a movie.
Let's just start recording them.
So can you recommend a movie you've seen
lately that you like? Dude, I watched, uh,
you've probably seen it I'm way behind,
but I just watched Batman versus
superman. I liked it. I've loved it, man.
You've already seen it all. Yeah,
I think it was great. I liked it.
I said that yesterday
at, uh, Benson's podcast.
Doug loves movies and everybody's
like, what? They were like,
they thought it was taking, what I
liked about is awesome. I liked the, uh,
sorry. I like the, uh, how
the, the way they had like the,
the government getting involved on,
we can't just have this
guy acting unilaterally and
whatever the fuck that means,
you know,
just,
just basically helping out who the fuck
he wants and people claiming him and all
that.
I was just going to hold accountable.
That actually seemed like some shit that
they would do and then demonize them
and all that. Like I always forget
movies the second I saw him,
but that thing stuck out with
me. I, I really liked that.
I thought it was great man.
And it's, it's uh, you know,
if you've ever seen a watchman, remember
that one? That's the same director, uh,
Zack Snyder, I think his name
is, he made the watchman,
which is like super dark,
super hero movie based on this
graphic novel, which is awesome.
You should check it out. You'd
love it. Here's the only,
the only thing called the comedian Oh,
cool. Superhero called the comedian.
He's like super dark.
The only thing I don't like about superman
movies is it always comes down to the
Kryptonite. It's always, it's never,
uh, he never bangs the wrong girl. It's,
you just know. Okay, where's the,
when's the green chain getting
wrapped around his neck? Yeah.
When's it gonna Happen?
That's the only thing that can do it.
The only thing that he's, he's
too powerful. That's the thing.
It almost gets a little
boring wealth. Well, Ben,
we finally got you on the podcast. I
finally got to play jam with you, man.
It was fucking awesome and a continued
success. Check out all things.
benBailey@therealbenbailey.com.
You can also get that by going to three
btb.net that's three baby t v.com B as
in baby, I should say. Dot
net.net. Sorry. Unfortunately,
it's dot.com is like some kids who have
a site with funny videos that suck.
I shouldn't say that. That's me. I know. I
know what you're okay, but it's not mine.
You went, you went for the joke. That
three B t v. Dot. Net. All right.
I'm gonna read a little bit of
advertising and that's going to be it.
I hope you guys have a good weekend and
I'll see on Monday. You fucking cool.
I'll see you.
All right. Is he advertising? He Nia.
Can you start moving the shit
around a track or we're all losers.
A Newsweek reports.
The average American wastes five minutes a
day looking for things they own but
can't find. Get the fuck Outta here.
55 minutes.
I'm a dope.
Only look for 48 fuck Newsweek.
No kidding.
Share a story of when you've
lost something, you need it. Oh,
I remember one time I was
taking a dump when I was like,
where's the toilet paper?
So I'm walking around with my
fucking belt around my legs.
Tracker makes losing things a thing of
the past and I'll tell you how to get one
for free in a minute. Tracker's a
coin size device that's locates,
misplaced keys, wallets, bags,
computers, anything in seconds.
Just pair tracker to you,
smashed phone,
attach it to anything and find his precise
locations with the tap of a button.
It's that easy. Lose your
phone. Oh Shit. There it is.
Press a button on tracker and your phone
rings even if it's when it's on silent.
Creepy tracker is finding over a
million misplaced items each day.
Order yours and never lose
anything. Again, listeners,
get listeners,
listeners to this show shit.
Get a free track or bravo with any order.
Go to the tracker.com and enter
the Promo Code [inaudible].
The hardest thing a level f you'll have,
we'll have to find is their website.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter
the Promo Code [inaudible] for your free
copy. What? True. Free track.
A Bravo with any order. Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Burr.
Hey,
where's the next read? Oh, there
it is. Thank you. Tracker, a lift.
You know about Lyft,
right?
It's the APP that gets you
rides in minutes on demand 24,
seven for less than the cost of a cab. Uh,
if you tried Lyft, you know what I mean?
With Lyft, you just download
the APP, request a driver,
and they show up in three and a half
minutes on average. That's really fast.
In case you didn't know there,
every Lyft driver is fully vetted
through their 10 point safety standard.
Have you ever killed anyone?
Two idiot jerk off when
you're driving three, right?
They go through the whole thing.
She'd be safe,
including criminal and
DMV background checks. Uh,
you'll know you'll get
around quickly and safely.
Why can't I read tonight?
Lyft drivers are rated after every
ride solely the best. Stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy card with some creepy dude.
Uh,
with Lyft you can tip in the APP would
obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean,
nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect
five star rating from the passengers.
It's just better all around experience.
Well, what happens on that 10th one?
We'll leave that up. Bigger
isn't always better. Um,
you fucking size queen lift isn't
the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing
in the highest rated one.
I'm talking quality over quantity. You
know where they're taking a shot at here.
It rhymes with scoober.
Um, thanks to lift,
you got an easy way to
avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride and you
never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are
actually getting right,
getting rid of their cars and relying on
Lyft to get around. And you know what?
I don't blame them. What if I did
say that you wrote that? Well,
if you live in Nebraska, I think you're
out of your fucking mind right now.
Lyft is offering our listeners a special
deal. Get three rides up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value.
You get those for free when you
enter the Promo Code Bill Burr, uh,
just download for free.
The Lyft app today and enter the Promo
Code Belper and the payment section.
You'll start with three free rides,
up to $10 each.
That's up to a $30 value. That's
Promo Code Bill Burr. Once again,
enter Promo Code Bill Burr.
I don't always stop this fucking thing,
Chris.
Home to unlock Jesus Christ.
All right. Yeah, I've got two more
here. Oh, here we go. Boop, boop, boop.
Me undies me on Andy's. Why did
you vote for Trump? The Dude,
dude, do me undies. Me undies.
America is taking a dump.
What were you supposed to fucking dude,
they got rid at Bernie.
Yeah, they had that fucking Twat. Alright.
Picture a world where poor putting it
out on a new pair of underwear isn't just
fresh. You're stepping into a better
day. Think of what, think about it under,
it's the first thing you put on,
the last thing you take off.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey.
Uh,
why would you settle for anything less
than the best feeling underwear on the
planet? Uh, Mian he's
focuses solely on the,
on producing the most comfortable
underwear you've ever experienced.
Your balls will. Thank you. Your Pussy
will also say, you know, it wasn't bad.
My friends at me undies semi of pair,
few a few pairs of while back and now
I can't imagine wearing anything else
evidentaly it really makes each day
that much better for the price of two
cocktails me undies,
we'll deliver your favorite new pair of
underwear right to your fucking doorstep.
Better,
better day guarantee you try them on.
If they're not the most
comfortable underwear, you know,
do a couple of scissor kicks.
Yeah, you're nuts. Fail.
If they're not the best
feeling undies you've ever had,
they'll refund you and let you
keep your first pair for free.
Included in the price is this
sweet touch of modal Modelo,
especial fabric made of the best in class
raw materials that are scientifically
proven to be three times
softer than cotton.
Now they've been saying that for a year
and the cotton people have not said Shit.
So unbelieving. That's true. These Uber
Cozy undies are sold exclusively on me.
Andy's website where you'll enjoy
free shipping in the US and Canada.
The rest of you can go fuck
yourselves. Um, and for a limited time,
everyone in my audience gets
20% off their first order.
But you have to go to our special URL,
me undies.com/bar with bmds that,
uh,
with the me on these better day
guarantee you have nothing to lose.
So don't wait any longer.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash per
right now for 20% off your phone,
your first order, that's [inaudible]
dot com slash burr and lastly,
but not leastly,
simply safe.
Ever find yourself almost
all the way to work.
Or maybe you're out with your family
and friends and you get that nagging
feeling, why did I marry this woman?
No, not that negative feeling.
You start thinking, did I close
that window? Did I lock the door?
You just don't know. It
could drive you nuts. Well,
you don't have to worry about that
anymore when you got simply safe home
security. Also, if you don't
buy any nice shit in your house,
you wouldn't care either.
But that's a different story.
It's a nice extra layer of protection
to know. Simply safe is there.
Simply safe has an arsenal of senses to,
uh,
to protect your entire home and
keep your family safe. Simply safe.
Got Rid of everything that
makes home security such a pain.
There's no long term contracts, no
hidden fees. They won't gouge you.
It's 1499 a month.
That's three times less than what other
companies judge and has some big news.
Simply safe just released its brand
new high definition security camera.
The camera is diff.
This camera's different,
connects to your security system
and sent your smartphone a video.
The second something happens at home.
Hey honey,
look at that guy stealing all our shit.
You can see the stubble on the side of
his face. This, this HD is incredible.
You can see everything that's going on
so you won't have to wonder anymore.
Call to action. Okay. Checkout
simply safe's new camera today.
Just go to simply save bird.com right
now. That's simply safe. bird.com hi.
Simply Safe burg.com all right,
that's it. Now I got, once again,
I got to hit the home button.
I got to do the whole password.
Good thing and that,
hey,
what's going on?
And still birth is the Monday
morning podcast and uh,
it's
late in the day.
And then I finally got to it and this
is my fourth attempt at trying to do a
good one. Get a good
one. How about that line?
What movie set from that times
at Ridgemont high? Mr Hand,
you remember him? Do you know the
guy who played that? He was in, uh,
my favorite Martian and he took
that gig back in the early sixties.
And so, so like 30 fucking
years, every time somebody
ran up to him they said, hey,
it's that fucking marsh and guy.
And he hated life and he
hated that fucking show.
And then he did that show movie
fast times at Ridgemont high.
And one day the clouds parted and some
young kid came walking up to him, said,
hey, mister hand. And evidently
he was really excited.
Isn't that a nice show?
Business Story?
I don't know what the fuck that has to
do with my podcast or this fucking bus
that is in front of me that is not
moving. Go, you're boss. There you go.
Merge, give con. Um, anyways, uh,
if you're new to my page or my website,
I do one of these every single week and
people send me questions and I tried to
answer them to the best of my ability.
I try not to say concert
during the podcast,
but occasionally it's flips out when
there's a broad us driving two miles an
hour. What the fuck is wrong
with me? I can't say words.
Lately I was working at xannies and
Nashville and I kept stumbling over words
and then I started thinking why I
keep stumbling over these words.
And then I almost started
stuttering on stage. And uh,
speaking of which, if you came up to
see me at Zinis in Nashville, Tennessee,
I just want to say thank you very much.
And I'm,
even though I just said
thank you very much,
you might have sensed a little bit of
anger underneath that and it has nothing
to do with you guys.
And it has to do with the fact that there
aren't enough hours in the day today
and I'm fucking frustrated.
And I basically only have about
10 15 minutes to do this podcast.
And you know, usually, usually
I go on for about 45 minutes,
but today or whatever,
half hour,
this is going to be like an EDP kind of
like guns and roses, that live album,
except I'm not going to drop the n word,
you know?
So slash if you're listening to this,
if you're one of the 14 people
who listens to my podcast,
you're not going to
feel awkward or have to
have to fucking explain yourself.
Um,
I don't fucking know people. You know
what? You know what? I got nothing.
I got nothing this week. I got nothing.
Funny to say. I am fucking burnt out.
I just did back to back weeks
on the road plus a college.
Do you want to hear them? You want
to hear my, uh, my week I was in a,
I always in Washington DC,
then I was in la and
then I went to Colorado,
then I flew to a Indianapolis,
did the Bob and Tom show and I
had a night off the night before.
And because my brain never
shuts off. I'm like, well,
why the fuck would I just chill out in
Indianapolis when I can drive for fucking
hours up to Detroit and go to a red
wings game? And that's what I did,
except I thought it was only a two hour
drive and it turned out it was a fucking
four hour drive, four and a half
actually. And I went up there,
it was Redwings penguins, which turned
out to be one of the games of the year,
but I had to leave before
the third period and did,
and I missed the penguins come
back and win and overtime.
But I still got to go to that arena and
I couldn't believe how small it was.
You know, there was no upper deck. It
just kind of went straight up. You know,
it was kind of an, I dunno, an old school
building and like a 1975 kind of way.
But, uh, it was really cool and
the fans were awesome. And uh,
you know,
I don't like going in that expansion
shit and I don't like fairweather fans.
And that's choice. Got Good
fans. And there were a lot
of Pittsburgh penguin fans.
They're talking a lot of shit.
Even when they were down
for two after two periods.
And I missed them all talking shit
when they came back and won seven,
six and fucking over time.
And where was I driving by fucking corn
field in the middle of Indiana. Bobby.
And
so my brain right now is fragile and um,
you know, you might wonder, uh, what the
fuck is wrong with bill and uh, you know,
I don't have any answers.
I'm driving a hybrid.
I just drank three quarters of a Sam
Adams Beer, one of their seasonal Bruce.
And I'm on my way to a writers meeting
because I have to go write some sketches
for something that I'm shooting and uh,
I'm exhausted.
This is one of these times when I
just want to sweep for fucking nine,
10 hours and wake up the next day
and just stare at the fucking wall.
But I can't because I have to do this.
I have to somehow put my voice into a
sketch, which is not an easy thing to do.
I find this very hard for me to write
sketches because I write very set up,
punch, set up, punch.
There's not a lot of layers that's
not a left model left turns, you know,
it's just like my act as a lot
of screaming and uh, the f word.
So you have to figure out how to do that.
And we're at a red light,
so I think it's time for a
podcast question. Look at this.
This is just like the cash cap. Uh,
okay. If don't question when. Number one,
have you ever been asked to write
material for another comedian?
First of all, look at this fucking guy
riding down the street with a bicycle.
I hate when got people do that.
They put a reflector on their back
and then all of a sudden they just,
they feel like they're like,
uh, this sort of like a,
a motorcycle on some level and they
start riding with traffic like the Kevin
Bacon and quick silver,
you know,
nothing makes me want to lean
over and open my passenger door
and commit vehicular manslaughter
like some fucking turn your life.
Somebody didn't have their lights
off. Um, like that. Do you know what?
I don't know what the fuck was I taught?
What was the question?
Have I ever been asked to write
material for another comedian? Uh, yes,
yes. I have. I have, uh, written for a,
I wrote for one roast is Shaquille
O'Neal roast. And I got to admit,
you know, at first I started
writing the jokes and I was like,
I don't want to write jokes
from another comedian.
I want to write them for me and I want to
be able to say, um, so I get the laugh.
But then I realized what's cool about a
roast is you're not at like writing for
Comedians to act whether then gonna go
on Hbo and kill with some joke and get
credit for it. Um, it's,
it's a very specific thing.
It's not like I have a chunk of
material about Shaquille O'Neal,
so what do I care? And I wrote it and
um, evidently it went really well.
People in the writer's room, I guess
liked it and I got a real kick out of it.
And, uh, I got one joke on the air.
I believe that joke was,
uh,
something about watching Shaquille O'Neal
play basketball was like watching a
retard fuck.
Something along those lines.
Something along of that. He
was just such a big dude. Yeah.
He's such a big fucking dude that
even when he's dunks the ball,
it doesn't look good.
He looks like a fat kid dunking
a ball on like a nerf hoop set.
And that was basically,
that was basically it.
I went the cheap route I use retard is a
reference stand out so I'm not proud of
it, but it got on the air.
All right, here's another one.
Do you agree that the reason many
TV shows or abruptly canceled,
the reason many TV shows or abruptly
canceled is due to the media is attempt to
control what we watch such as reality TV.
Okay.
Um, the media, his attempt is it,
the entire media is working together.
Um,
if you're in the conspiracy theory,
I would work a little higher up the ladder
and try to see who owns media in this
country. And you'd be surprised.
It's not that many people. So,
uh,
I dunno,
I don't think reality TV is an attempt to
Pete for them to control what we watch.
I just think it's really cheap and it's a,
there's something mesmerizing about
watching 10 losers in a house.
Talk Shit about each other
as much as I make fun of it.
Did that guy just fucking bump into me?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You fucking idiot.
But like just fucking rear ended me.
Hmm.
Hang on a second.
Okay.
Fucking do this. I'll fuck
away. He just did that
quite a gut. I think some guy
just literally tapped my bumper.
Hang on a sec.
You know what?
This would be great if we get to a fucking
red light cause I know we didn't hit
it hard enough. Hold on, hold on a second.
Bump into me.
Hang on a sec.
Did you just bumped into
me? You didn't? Okay.
I don't know if was my car or not.
I was wonder why he has such a nonchalant
look on your face. I'm like, all right,
I'm just making sure. All
right. Sorry about that.
Okay. Hi. Hi Ma. Okay.
So anyways,
me even didn't into me.
I think my car just had like a hiccup,
but it literally felt like
somebody just tapped my buck
and I looked in the rear view mirror.
This guy was right on my fucking ass.
You guys almost started in La moment.
Okay,
what is, I fought him.
I want to fuck. Fuck.
And if the I have enough
speaker phone do it,
then they could have
used my podcast in court.
Then I finally would have got like
50 fucking listeners. God dammit.
That was, that was a moment right there.
That was a moment that almost happened.
What a stupid question. Oh, did you just
go up into me? Ah, no I didn't. Oh, okay.
Jesus. Can you believe I'm not a
private investigator with that?
That's sort of fucking police
work. All right. So anyways,
anyway, Shit. I gotta wrap this podcast
up cause I'm at where the fuck I'm at.
So this guy being writer's thing that
I'm doing, but you gotta admit, you know,
that was pretty exciting that for
a second. Um, all right, let's,
let's start a bloke who, some of these
more, some more of these questions,
but before I get the phone,
thanks to everybody who came up to see
me at saint e's in Nashville, Tennessee,
I had an awesome time and literally tons
more people showed up since the last
time. It's really made me feel good that,
you know, people actually saw my special,
they liked it and it made
him want to come out. And uh,
I'm really psyched about that.
And I know I've been telling you guys
I'm putting the dates up for 2009.
They're definitely getting up this
week. I talked to my booker and, uh,
there's supposed to be
emailing me something.
So I'll get the dates up up on my website,
up on my myspace page.
Please come out to see me and you'll
watch me put together my next special that
hopefully I will take this
summer coming summer. So anyways,
here's a long question about
corporate America. Hey Bill,
let me tell you why I effing hate
corporate America, especially Verizon.
Exclamation point.
They sold me a blackberry that recently
for the fifth time to keyboard,
wouldn't work, couldn't make or
answer calls and couldn't do anything.
Each time it would happen, I'd go to
Verizon, they would fix it for me,
but the last time,
a few weeks ago,
a buddy of mine in the army was cost the
day before he shipped off to Iraq and I
was unable to answer the call. Jesus,
that sounds like a lifetime movie,
like phone,
I need to say goodbye.
So I went to Verizon furiously as you
should have demanding an explanation on
why they sold so me such a shitty phone.
They told me that they could do was
replace it with the same model phone in
which my response was all you'd be doing
is giving me a shiny or piece of shit.
Ah, God bless you. God bless you.
That's exactly what you should've said
and then shouldn't taken the phone and
buries inside of his head and blamed
him for that design is if he designed it
all right.
Leading me.
And this basically led him to sign up
with a t and t and now Verizon wants to
charge me with $125 early termination fee.
I've been arguing my case with them on
the phone trying to explain to them that
if I still had Verizon I wouldn't
be able to make this phone call.
They kept telling me that they understand
why I'm except upset and which my
response was great.
So if you understand why you still ask
for my money and basically there is no
way that I'm going to buckle and give
it into them. Good, good for you.
I keep calling them disputing them.
I'll keep calling them to spooling
up for two years if I have to.
To me it's a matter of principle
because what pisses me off is how these
corporations are allowed to
conduct business. You know,
I don't even need the rest of the three.
The rest is exactly exactly that.
They're bigger than you and they have
more money than you and they can wait you
out and then they can send you shift
to a collection agency cause you're the
little guy. And they know that
you're not going to do that.
This is what you want to do. You want to,
you've got to do that old school thing.
Just go,
I want it to speak to a manager and you
keep going up the ladder asking to speak
to somebody, bumped them,
get everybody's name,
keep using words like
ridiculous and outrageous.
Like this is ridiculous.
This is outrageous.
And a just do it the way like
an old lady would and just,
just don't get off the phone. Don't
ever curse. If you never curse,
then they can't.
Uh,
they can't hang up on you. I'm full
of Shit. I don't know what to do.
You know what? Go burn down their
fucking building or something.
But I'm sorry man, I really didn't
answer that question well, but uh,
I got to go in and do this meeting,
so whatever.
Thanks for listening to the Monday morning
podcast. I know this was real short,
but hey,
we had a nice yelling match with potential
yelling match with another person in
the car,
which turned out to be friendly.
How bad did you guys want that to
escalate into violence? You know, you did.
Then you could have heard
me get my ass kicked.
I that guy just rolled down the window
like I've ever taken a karate class.
It was fucking ridiculous. But
fortunately, shit didn't go down that way.
So anyways, it was very short,
very exciting. Tj Hooker,
episode of a,
the Monday morning podcast.
Keep listening and please keep
sending the questions and, uh,
that is that God bless all of you.
Please come and see me at Carolines in
New York City the first week in December.
And, uh, that is it. And I apologize
to the guy who I thought hit my car,
but really didn't, if he's a
podcast listener. All right,
dude. That's it. All right,
good. I take it easy. Bye to take it
easy. I take it easy. Bye. Alright.
Take it easy.
Bye.